all of us who learn languages and myself  included we eventually want to speak we  want to output even though link  emphasizes input and recognizes the  importance of input in making our brain  familiar with the language the words the  phrases the pronunciation eventually we  want to output output a good place to  start is writing because there's no  pressure you can look things up you can  look up the correct ending you know the  correct tends to use or other  grammatical points you can check the  word in your vocabulary section or you  can save a bunch of words let's say that  you've tagged and then try to use these  words in your writing and other members  of our community can correct these for  you in the exchange and then you can  import this as learning material so for  those of you who are prepared to  practice writing make it a habit to  write a little bit because it's a good  way to start yourself towards being a  more comfortable speaker of the language